welcome to a day plus real talk it's
been one year since Mike Brown was
killed by cop in Ferguson Missouri the
last 12 months had been all about black
lives matter and racism in America we
discuss all this happened since last
year and on Thursday night Jon Stewart
took his last bout his host of The Daily
Show will look back on what he's meant
to America let's get started I'm done
whoo and joining me now is I senior
producer Brooke Brooke what's up yeah
what's up she was on the ground cover
you sink covering Ferguson last year
brooke has America changed since last
year shooting I'm think a little bit I'm
see a little bit with me a little bit I
mean that I think we still got a long
way to go to get everybody on the same
page but I think a lot of Americans now
are realizing that black people weren't
lying when they said police were
shooting them in record numbers what was
it about Mike Brown that that brought
this to the forefront they're still
within video of mike brown being shot so
like but why did Mike Brown spark this
decision I think there were several
factors one I mean his body laid in the
street for four hours I think where it
happened and may have not been the best
city for it to happen in Ferguson I
think people were already really fed up
sick and tired of being sick and tired I
guess you could say so i think it was
like a turning point in that city and
this is just all the images that came
out of that all the social media really
galvanize people and then people came
out to protest his death to protest what
had happened or to find out what
actually had happened cuz people didn't
know and the police are being so mom on
it and the way that the police responded
to the people on the street who wanted
who were demanding answers I couldn't
agree with you more I saw the police the
militarized police that mean I tanks the
body only the snipers I was like this is
all over a shooting I mean yet I get
coming out to stop on wrestle whatnot
but still at the industry it was a bit
extreme yeah it was a dad what how the
police reacted did not did analysis that
messages excuse me did not necessitate
what what people were doing right you
know and i think we started here some of
the audio from the cops reaction to the
protesters like I'm gonna I'm gonna kill
you you effing an animal or whatever it
might be it's crazy completely crazy
yeah you know how do you think black
lives matter change the conversation
about the way people look at police
brutality in America
I think could change the cartridge by
giving giving the actual name to the
conversation saying black lives do
matter so I think that's how they were
able to shift what where the
conversation was going and to focus on
the police brutality was happening more
towards african-americans I couldn't
agree with you more um as always Brooke
pleasure to have you I'll see you next
week all right next one of our producers
Kate joins me the daily show with jon
stewart may have ended this week but she
and many other definitely gonna miss him
I know I will what's up Kate hey you
worked on the piece of our Jon Stewart
impact on the media politics and the
u.s. how could a TV host comic become so
it went influential and powerful well
obviously he was funny oh he's really
funny right i mean in a time of a war
awful terrorist attack a president that
was not living up to our standards I
feel like a lot of people really
connected with what John was joking
about but also I think John would never
say he was a journalist right but he had
the tools and the the ability to say
things that traditional journalists
couldn't say so when it came to you know
CNN anchors and reporters have to have
this veneer of valence right and I think
John made it his point to not have that
he never said he was fair and balanced
but he did so much more to the truth and
brutally honest he's super honest and I
think we learned a lot because of that I
really loved how he was able to like
listen to a politician of somebody talk
and say you know what you said XYZ but
in nineteen some odd you said right be
your friend he used the hypocritical
politician right what they said five
years ago what they said today put them
side by side and I member watching that
as a journalist in college and there in
the mid-2000s and going why doesn't
every anchor do that and then John could
add sketches and hyperbole and jokes and
go into a way that other journalists
because they're trying to be balanced
they're trying to not lose contact to
their source they couldn't do and it
wasn't just John doing it like this
might be making me come across a little
nerdy but I was a really big fan of the
view in college all the women talking
because again they're not saying they're
journalists it was Whoopi Goldberg Joy
Behar oh yeah Rosie but they were able
to question the politicians like mccain
and obama and clinton in a way that that
other journals just don't do because
they don't want to be like oh I don't
want people to think we're biased
what do you think some of his
shortcomings where I think towards the
end Jon Stewart was harping on the media
a lot on Fox I mean like we did it Fox
News's this way we get it John he's
going on the top right now right right
and I think he's so it's time for me to
go I get it John Oliver then when he
came on with last week tonight on HBO
his show now is a lot more explaining
the issues in a way that I think Jon
used to Jon Stewart used to do and so
now John Oliver is doing it's sort of
taking over and I'm really into that
show he talks for like 17 minutes on the
most boring topic but I'm interested
thanks so much for joining absolutely no
doubt all right thank you guys for
watching keep it like to aj+ for more
news videos and stories we're in all
your social media feeds so finance their
piece
you